- [Narrator] These
paintings, they aren't done
with acrylic, oil, or watercolor.
- [Narrator] Microsoft
Excel, the computer program.
This is a story about Tatsuo,
the Microsoft Excel Artist.
(bouncy electronic music)
- [Narrator] When Tatsuo
retired, he decided
he wanted to paint, but there
was one problem: he was cheap.
- [Narrator] He didn't even
want to pay for an art program,
so he used what was
already on his computer.
- [Narrator] So, how do you paint in Excel?
The line tool, it's usually
used for spreadsheet graphs,
that you can make trees
with, and the bucket tool,
it helps with subtle
shading on, for example,
the crest of a volcano.
(bell dinging)